So this is another place where you might find
C02 everyday at work or
maybe even at home in the kitchen.
We use it in fire extinguishers. Now if we
shake this bottle we can hear
that there's some liquid slopping around inside
and that's liquefied C02.
So C02 is useful as an extinguisher for fires
because it doesn't erm sustain
combustion it's non-flammable. So if there
is a fire, we squirt C02 which
is quite dense; it blankets over the fire,
excludes oxygen and puts the
fire out. So let's see some more gaseous C02.
Carbon dioxide is a really interesting molecule.
It's very simple. It has
carbon here with two oxygen atoms one on each
side so it’s just three
atoms in a row.
Today what we're going to do is we're going
to explore the three states
of matter looking at a single molecule and
we’re going to use C02. So at
standard temperature and pressure, C02's a
gas and actually I’m
breathing it out so here we go we'll make
some C02 [breathes out].
The molecule has many interesting properties.
One of them is that most
gases, when you compress them, will liquefy
and form a liquid and then if you
cool the liquid down it will freeze. What
is interesting about Carbon
Dioxide is that you cannot get the liquid
at atmospheric pressure. So you
can get all sorts of little containers that
contain liquid C02 but if you open
them, release the pressure, the C02 converts
into a solid, so called dry
ice, which is very cold but goes straight
from the solid to the gas without erm
melting.
So hopefully today we’re going to look at
C02 as a gas, C02 as a liquid
and C02 as a solid and perhaps we’ll look
at some reactions as well.
There are double bonds between the carbon
and the oxygen because
each oxygen normally wants to be bonded to
two atoms but here you
can see it's only bonded to one carbon so
it has a double bond, two
bonds together.
So this is where we're going to get our C02
from, this rather large
cylinder. So on the cylinder we have a device
called a regulator which
you can see here. Now what that does is it
limits the pressure of the gas
that we get out into our pipe. So this is
really for safety because the
pressure inside the cylinder is a lot higher
than the pressure that we
require in our reaction or inside our balloon.
So here we have a balloon,
a rather strange balloon. So now you can see
we’ve collected a balloon
full of carbon dioxide and as you can see
it’s a rather nice balloon, the same
as any other balloon, what do you say about
a balloon and C02? So C02
is a gas [laughs]
C02 is one of my favourite molecules because
C02 as a liquid or a highly
compressed gas will dissolve chemicals just
in the same way as petrol or
other organic liquids will dissolve them and
so you can use carbon
dioxide as a solvent for chemical reactions
and this highly compressed
gas, the so called super critical fluid, is
something that both I and Pete
Licence, who does lots of our demonstrations,
we've done a lot of
research on this.
Most people when they think of C02 they think
of it as a gas but if you
take that gas and you pressurise that gas
and you squeeze it, if you put
it into a bottle perhaps or a container and
you squeeze it, the gas
molecules are brought closer and closer and
closer together until
eventually they will condense and form a liquid
phase. Now what we’ve
done with our experiment, is we’ve taken
the C02 and we've connected
it to a special piece of apparatus which you
can see is made out of things
like stainless steel and technical instrumentation.
But the key thing about
this apparatus is that unlike a normal stainless
steel vessel we have a
window inside this vessel which is able to
maintain pressure, it’s able to
take the stresses because of the pressure
trying to erm push against the
atmosphere.
And it's really good for chemical reactions
and again by using carbon
dioxide as a solvent, you can avoid having
to use products made from
petroleum which might otherwise use up and
deplete the petroleum. With
carbon dioxide, we have more than we know
what to do with from
various industrial processes. So it is available
really quite widely.
So the window that you’re looking through
in this experiment is sapphire.
That must be expensive
Hell yes, they're about, the front window
in this cell is approximately
£800 and the rear window, the one which moves,
is about £1400. So
quite expensive but absolutely critical for
this experiment.
And if, as is proposed, C02 is captured from
power stations this could be
huge amounts of C02 and if you can use that
for chemical reactions, for
extracting materials. One of the main commercial
applications of high
pressure carbon dioxide at the moment is for
decaffeinating coffee.
Many years ago, coffee was decaffeinated using
dry cleaning fluids which
can leave all sorts of residues in the coffee
beans, people may not want
to drink the coffee. But caffeine is soluble
in C02 and most of the other
components of coffee beans are not so you
can extract the caffeine
from green coffee beans so you get decaffeinated
coffee and the C02
leaves no residues at all and then by reducing
the pressure or washing
the C02 with water you can get the caffeine
out and you can sell it to
people to put in their soft drinks.
Now, Neil's been really active and he's ordered
in a special piece of C02
for us which he's going to get out of the
box now. So erm what we
thought we'd do today is perhaps a little
bit of erm ice sculpting. So
we're going to cut the C02 in half and make
a reaction vessel. Ok? And
then we're going to do a nice chemical reaction
with it. So here Neil’s
cutting the C02 now with a saw. Now this is
a typical saw that you might
find in a hardware shop or a do it yourself
shop. So one of the
advantages of sawing this material is that
you don't have to clean up the
saw dust because it just evaporates.